okay so the Last of Us episode four is
now out and throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down all the Easter
eggs hidden details and game differences
this sees Joel and Ali arriving in
Kansas City to find it run by a new
villain that didn't actually appear in
the original game Kathleen brings in
extra Dimension with her and throughout
this video we're gonna be going through
everything that happens in the entry as
always we will be saving games spoilers
until the end of the video so you don't
have to worry about having click it on
the wrong one another way I'm your host
Paul welcome back to the heavy spoilers
show now let's get into the breakdown
now the entry starts off with Ali aiming
the gun that she got from Bells at
herself in a mirror instantly I got a
lot of Vibes of Taxi Driver with a now
feeling like she's able to handle
herself because of it in the original
game Jill forbidder from having one
initially and the plot with Belle played
out completely differently it wasn't the
stuff with Frank unless she couldn't
just take one from his home it's also
important to bear in mind that in the
episode Joel says they're in Kansas City
whereas in the game it all goes down in
Pittsburgh we're not in Pittsburgh
anymore Dorothy and when talking about
the gamer show I'll use them
interchangeably but it also means that
some of the landmarks of the cities are
different in the game you constantly had
the yellow Bridge off in the background
and this acted as a waypoint for you to
get to upon arriving in Pittsburgh they
went into the hotel that was at the
start of episode 2 and they ended up
being split up with Joel having to make
his way through the basement eventually
he emerged on the other side but he was
ambushed by a rider who then tried to
drown him this doesn't will get played
up in this episode with a guy in the
store almost killing him like what
happened in the hotel in both instances
says Ellie saves his life and after this
Joel started to trust her he even gave
her a rifle immediately after so that
she could watch over him and then once
he'd completed this section he then
handed over the gun now the gun in the
game was originally taken from a dead
Hunter and it was purposely picked to be
the same model as the one that Marlin
used in order to show how the two were
linked the game developers modeled it
after a Beretta 70 series lightweight
pistol but in the game it was just
called a 71 Jaguar now we see this whole
scene playing out in a gas station
bathroom and I love how they transformed
the location to make it feel like it's
ripped right out of the source material
gas stations also appeared in the
original Dawn of the Dead and the group
there had a way more tense encounter
than the punishment Joel subjected to
mathematically this meant to reflect the
ending of the episode in which we see
Sam Ali is a child holding up a gun and
it seems like it's all pun in games at
the end though they're left with Sam
potting when I Joel and we see how kids
have kind of been stripped of their
childhood they've been brought into this
world that might initially seem exciting
and fun but there's people after them
around every corner she ends up having
to shoot someone and I love how there's
these three moments that all mirror each
other now outside we see Joel siphoning
Peril from a car and it's possible that
he picked up this tank and Tube at
Bill's house in the game Bill gave it
directly to him but obviously with him
being dead last week he probably grabbed
it from the storage
here
what's this you'd be amazed at how many
cars still got gas in them
appreciate it Joe has to stop regularly
because petrols pretty much turned into
water over the past 20 years and it
explains why people aren't just driving
around in cars all the time except for
those sky-high gas prices eh I'm all
right am I right it's topical it's
topical now else they weighed Ellie
busts out something that comes directly
from the game this is no pun intended
Volume 2 with the two smelt like a t
double o
it's a good joke and and it as I said
it's ripped right out of the game and
even some of the puns we get in the
entry of verbatim to what they are on
the PlayStation counterpart no pun
intended volume two but we're all
Livingston it's a joke book no pun
intended Volume 2 by Will Livingston
it doesn't matter how much you push the
envelope it'll still be stationary
what did the mermaid where did her math
class
what did the mermaid wear to her math
class what
and algebra an algae bra
I stayed up all night wondering where
the sun went then it dawned on me I
stayed up all night wondering where the
sun went and then it dawned on me now we
will talk later on about how she got
this in our super spoiler section as it
is foreshadowing an episode that will
probably get down the line it first
appeared in the alone and forsaken
chapter which took place in Pittsburgh
and this episode's basically adapting
that storyline alone and forsaken is
also the name of the Hank Williams song
that they play in his car and this two
appeared in the game as they rode into
the town I actually did a trailer
breakdown a while back that pointed this
out but then the estate of Hank Williams
claimed it and blocked the video so no
hunks I won't be using it here I like
the way I slowly grind my viewers down
with the worst puns imaginable we see
Joel holding back a smile slowly he is
warming to Ellie and at this point
they've been together for a couple of
weeks like the game she busts out jokes
from and at several key parts of the
episode in which they go to sleep ever
since the death of Sarah Jill spent his
life around adults and Ellie doing this
very much reminds him of how much light
his daughter brought into his life he
has been completely called to kids and
didn't even Flinch when throwing the
body of one into a fire he carried this
in the same way that he carried Sarah
but it was completely unemotional for
him and now just a part of life however
Ellie very much brings with her the
possibility of regaining the happiness
that he lost and this is why he becomes
so protective over her when they sleep
he always puts himself facing the danger
and stacked in front of her because
subconsciously he won't let anything bad
happen to her no matter what we discover
that the cars in the road have been
shifted out the way by modified vehicles
that were fed with plows sitting on the
front this is very much foreshadowing
the Run truck which two appeared in the
game it chase you throughout Pittsburgh
and was constantly pinning you down with
gunfire as you made your way throughout
the city Ellie finds a certain kind of
magazine and the dialogue here is all
pulled right out of the game
sir right on the reading when it has
some interesting pictures
light on the reading but it's got some
interesting photos that Ellie that ain't
for kids setback that's not for kids
please get rid of it use your horses I
want to see what all the fuss is about
whoa
how how the hell could he even walk
around with that thing get rid of that
beat your horses I want to see what all
the fuss is about
iron orders Pages stuck together oh why
are these all stuck together
I'm just [__] with you
yes
bye-bye dude
[Music]
now as they make their way out on the
road we see abandoned cars and theme
parks which of course show the fall of
humanity however we also catch a field
of Buffalo and I think symbolically this
has been chosen for a reason the fall of
humanity hasn't doomed the rest of
Nature and throughout the game we see
how it thrived in our absence bison were
actually almost sent it to Extinction
during the wild west and I think this
animal specifically shows how the
world's moving on without us at this
point they pass through a town in a
bridge though it's not the same as the
one in Pittsburgh I think this has been
chosen because it resembles it and they
want to give a little nod to the game as
you made your way through the city you
had this constantly off in the
background and the yellow beams on it
acted as a guide that would lead you out
of danger and we see several boats in
the river that have all capsized and
it's almost like a graveyard with
everything falling into disrepair
everything is a monument almost like a
fossil showing what's come and what's
now extinct you pass the FedEx Depot
that's full of trucks and military
vehicles lining up the road it showcases
how everything and everyone was affected
and how the entire world came to a
standstill that's now Frozen in place
there's a great Highway shot where we
see a collapse train in the background I
love how every Landmark they pass has
its own story that's likely a horrifying
moment in someone else's life now there
was a section in part two where you had
to navigate through a train station
containing several collapsed trains
which this could be a nod to the map
navigation as well was also something
that popped up in the games when hitting
open World areas you'd often use maps to
navigate them and this ties in with the
more subtle nods to the games that we've
seen throughout the episodes we've had
the workbenches magazines that have
upgrade branches in them and Joel even
slumped his backpack of his shoulders
similar to what he does in the game when
he's crafting when discussing this on
the HBO podcast the creative team said
that they actually wanted every episode
to open with a window that hinted to
what would be happening in the entry
instead of the skip intro button they'd
also have it say press play tying it in
further with the games now we also see
as I pass the sign for Orbeez which is a
nice little nod to this line from last
week if I feed you then every bum you
talk to about it is going to show up
here looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's now this video
is sponsored by Magic spoon since having
kids I had put on a couple of pounds and
I'd been looking to lose weight over
roughly the last three months that's why
I was really excited team up with magic
spoon who offer a high protein zero gram
sugar cereal that fits perfectly into a
low carb diet each one's roughly 140
calories and it tastes so good I really
can't see myself going back to any other
brand magic spoon takes you back to
those days where you go and watch your
Saturday morning cartoon with a big bowl
of cereal and the never boring breakfast
brings out your inner child in a big way
what's great about magic spoon is that
it's all high protein and the
nutritional benefits can be found on the
box right on the front so you know
exactly what you're getting like I said
it's got zero grams of sugar it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain free and full
of natural flavors again not putting
this stuff down I love the cocoa flavor
and I can say Hannah that I think you're
gonna love it too start the new year off
right with magic spoon and click the
link in the description below to pick up
a variety pack and try today be sure to
use the code heavy spoilers at checkout
for five dollars off any order or you
can go to magicspoon.com heavy spoilers
magic spoon is so confident that you're
gonna love this cereal that they have a
100 happiness guarantee so for any
reason if you're not feeling it don't
know why you wouldn't but they'll refund
any of the money no questions asked so
scan the QR code on screen right now or
click the link below in the description
and go to magicspoon.com heavy spoilers
and enter heavy spoilers at the checkout
for five dollars off thanks now in a
brand new scene for the story we see as
they go off-road and park up in a forest
in the game they continued on the road
to Pittsburgh and after Ellie fell
asleep you woke up arriving at the town
when discussing this in the HBO podcast
the creative team said that in the game
you're very much just constantly pushing
forward but because you're playing and
they want to keep you involved however a
TV show can take breaks and show us the
nights and days that just wouldn't
happen in a game this is most notably
seen in episode 2 where they bunker down
in Boston and in the game you pushed on
through the night after leaving the qz
and dude it being an episode they can do
things like this instead of constantly
trying to keep you playing like Cowboys
in the wild west they eat food out of
metallic plates and these were made of
tin back in the olden days which meant
they could be washed quickly they Feast
on 20 year old ravioli from Bell's
supplies and Ali asks if they can light
up a fire for the night Joel says no
initially and she suspects it's because
the infected will see the smoke the in
fact it didn't really perceive things
like smoke as being related to humans
and even lights themselves weren't
something that can set it to me and
there were people in the area during the
game you can wander around with your
flashlight on because they just didn't
perceive that as being linked to a
person Joel says that people are the
real danger out here and this is the
first real point in the season when we
get the idea that humans are even more
dangerous than the infected Raiders and
slavers were mentioned in episode 1 and
though we saw some in Lincoln they
weren't things gel and I experienced
this is different in the game and at
this point you'd face stuff against
fedra and Robert's men however I didn't
even realize until now that it wasn't
until Pittsburgh that you actually
encountered humans that weren't acting
in the QC there were some that would
enslave people and others that would do
even worse oh yeah at this point also
has her bag out and we can see the
little Cyclops head that he also had in
the game anyway they bunker down for the
night with Ellie once more trying to
read from the puns book why did the
Scarecrow get an award
why did the Scarecrow get a promotion
all right
standing in his field
dick because he was outstanding in his
field
that'll do put that thing away but y'all
actually laughs for what what I think is
the first time since Sarah's death and
no he reassures them that they're safe
he looks in the forest before turning to
his gun Joe con rest then we then catch
him standing guard in the night looking
out into the darkness it's a very eerie
moment filled with beer and paranoia and
the fact that Jill is so wary over what
could happen is because he's done some
horrible things he alluded to this later
on after the Ambush and we'll go into
what this actually means now this is how
he knew it was a trap and why he's also
afraid of what could happen here anyway
Ellie looks out on the stars and in the
game this could be linking him with
something that I'll talk about more
later on I keep dangling that characters
to make you stay till the end of the
video but there are very interesting
points here that I think definitely are
worth discussing now in the morning we
see jealous making coffee and there were
several points in the game where he
talking about how much he loved it
I did
all the time
[Music]
just
coffee
I really miss coffee
this happened during the hotel bed and
we later learned he traded a lot of his
supplies for a bag of beans in the
second game any remarked that she
thought it tasted like Burns and that
line sort of gets brought across here
thank you
acquired taste my ass it smells like
burnt [__] I Joel and Ali talk about
where Tommy could be and they bring up
Cody this is located in Wyoming and it's
a location that they mentioned before
when discussing where Tommy is we
actually learn a bit about him that we
went privy to in the game and it
explains the Desert Storm sticker that
we saw in the first episode we touched
upon this during that but the reason
that Tommy got so high up in the
fireflies was because he was a skilled
Soldier we discovered that he joined a
group making their way to Boston and
Joel went along with him in order to try
and keep him alive yeah they met Tess
and the HBO podcast for the show
building some of her backstory that we
haven't really been privy to we
discovered that Tess had a husband and
son and when the outbreak happened she
ended up killing the former she couldn't
bring herself to do the latter though so
she ended up locking him in the basement
much in the same way that Ellie was a
representation of Sarah for Joel she was
also one for Tess but the scene
explaining this was unfortunately
scrapped a Joel is clearly opening up to
her as he's lowering his walls and it's
a complete 180 from last week when
refuse to tell her anything in fact we
just keep our histories to ourselves
matter of fact we can just keep our
histories to ourselves at this point
Tommy joined the fireflies after meeting
Marlene Joel says that he quit and we'll
talk about what happened to him in the
super spoiler section
now Joel says that he's only taking Ali
because he made a promise to Tess and
that she's cargo this is what he also
refers to her being in the game and she
wonders why he even bothers living if he
doesn't have attachments or anything
that he actually cares about you do kind
of wonder why Joe keeps going when he
doesn't really have anything to live for
but in the game he says you find
something that constantly keeps you
pushing to survive it's also at this
point that I noticed Bella Ramsay has a
cut in her eyebrow and this is the same
one as Ellie has in the game you also
get a scene that pulls directly from it
with Ellie falling asleep on the road
got it pretty early if you want to grab
more sleep I'm not even tired she tried
to get some sleep all right I'm not even
tired
no one making their way to Kansas
they're faced with the same issue that
they had in the game on outbreak day
many people tried to flee the area and
because of this highways became backed
up what sucks is that in the show he can
see through the tunnel to the other side
but unfortunately they can't get through
it and the game he stops and says screw
before taking a turn to the right this
leads them directly into an ambush this
is likely why the road was shut up in
the first place as that's what I always
thought when I was playing the game as
they drive through the city we can also
catch a theater playing underworld and
Matchstick Men which were both released
in 2003. you also pass a pile of burnt
corpses and in the game after surviving
the Ambush you got to the other side and
found something similar to this it's
like you know it could over easily be
new and it's a harrowing sight to see
that I think even has a child amongst
them make matters worse bedra have been
overthrown and the checkpoint gate is
now wide open this is probably a good
thing though I think as Ali likely would
have been scanned and then shot for
being infected anyway at this point we
get the Ambush playing out and let's
play these together so you can see how
the scenes compare
are we gonna help him
your seatbelt on Ellie
what about the guy oh he ain't even hurt
are we gonna help him
[Music]
[Applause]
now whereas in the game they were rammed
off the road by a bus in the show their
tires are popped and they end up
crashing into a laundromat they use
similar shots with a cameraman filming
from behind them and we watched them
drive directly into the crash point and
this was one of the most tensest scenes
in the game and they just immediately
dropped you into the action without
giving you time to breathe sometimes
games will be like cool mate cutscenes
over and then they'll put you into the
thick of it which is exactly what
happened here when you were playing it
Joel almost got his face shoved into
some broken glass and you had to fight
to survive as Hunters swarmed the area
when the episode early hides in a hole
in the wall and Joel takes out the
Raiders that close in we can see he's
carrying his rifle from the PlayStation
classic and this is called a Mossberg
500 they really managed to recapture
what it's like being stuck in these gun
fights and you constantly have to shoot
and move as the enemy AI would have them
constantly bearing down on you at this
point a guy busts in attack Joe loud and
he almost kills him he's saved by Ali
who shoots the man there and like I said
earlier this is riffing on the scene
from the hotel they framed it in the
same way with the writer being on top
pinning Joe down and Ellie ends up
coming behind him in the game it was
sort of a deus ex machina as we didn't
know Ellie was there but here we see
things from her point of view we also
sort of get an extended scene in which
the guy doesn't die and he begs for his
life again moments like this appeared in
the source material and when you beat a
person badly enough they'd sometimes
plea for you to let them go oh
man let's be cool man take it easy
no no it's okay it's okay it's over
we're not fighting anymore look man we
can work something out okay
we can trade with you guys we can't be
friends I didn't know the guy here Brian
begs not to be killed and now Ellie
doesn't deliver the final blow Joel does
during this bit Brian brought up his
mother and we did kind of go back and
forth in the heavy spoiler's office
about who exactly this was there was
potential it could be Kathleen and
that's kind of what we debated over but
she doesn't seem that upset later on she
seems more focused on having a reason to
arm people against the Traders and she
uses his death as a way to do this they
push a desk in front of a door to block
it and this is something you'd often do
in the game to stop the infected and
hunters from following you and we see
trucks patrolling the street calling out
for Brian and this is riffing on moments
in the game when he killed someone and
their crew would call out for them
all right God
Zach what
it's Mateo he's dead spoiler alert
first introduced in part two this added
a lot of depth to the combat and it was
one of the key features that they pushed
when promoting the game they even went
back and added it into the part 1 remake
as hearing people call out for someone
you just killed makes it all the more
personal cut across to some soldiers
who've made makeshift uniforms out of
fedra body armor and helmets and went
now with some Rebels here we meet
Kathleen for the first time and we catch
her interrogating a man that we learn as
a doctor his band of rebels has just
taken over the QC recently and they've
added fedra in order to replace them in
the game you pretty much got the idea
early on that Federer were very bad but
when he traveled to places that had
stumped them out he saw the rebels were
even worse they have a sign up saying
that those in detention still have basic
human rights but Kathleen doesn't offer
any of these to the doctor she ends up
murdering him and this is her basically
showing a no tolerance policy for people
that lie to her played by Melanie
lynskey you might recognize her from
Yellowjackets and even though she's
small and reserved she dominates the
scene she's in now we discovered that
here brother was interrogated by Federer
at some point and that they ended up
killing him being the leader of the
rebels this likely pushed her over the
edge and it's what forced them to
overthrow fedra and their fascist ways
this entire interrogation is in order
for her to find Henry and Sam oh we get
a brief glimpse of at the end of the
episode now Super Soap and spoiler
section will be going through who this
is and it's clear they were some people
like the Doctor Who were working with
fedra who are probably playing both
sides of the fence and the doctor would
of course be very valuable in this new
world due to so few people having
medical qualifications he says that he
was threatened by Federer and this is of
course murdered and Kathleen here
showing how power can corrupt no matter
who's in charge my guess is that the
doctor was some kind of informant or
something and he snitched to fedra in
order to get certain benefits Henry
seems to have been as well and from the
off a Kanga that he was the one he told
fedra about her brother which led to
them murdering him he feels secure with
a gun to his head and says that because
he's a doctor that she won't kill him
also talk later about why this line is
really important and how Kathleen may be
a reflection of another character now at
this point she hears horns blaring
outside and sees Brian dead on the
ground there is a curtain his chest and
it's lucky that Joel stabbed him with a
knife that Brian tried to give him so
that he'd let him go makes me one day if
the knife could pop up again and
Kathleen may possibly find it on Joel
and put two and two together she blames
Henry for this assuming that he's found
a radio and called Joel and alien which
makes him an even bigger Target Kathleen
initi wants to use the doctor to save
one of their lives but after hearing
he's got no chance she mercilessly
shoots him in Cold Blood Joel has very
much inadvertently started war and this
attack now allows her to arm everyone up
in order to go and search for them even
the killing of a doctor will likely be
over luck now because she has a reason
to pin blame on him and people will
forgive her because of how bad things
have gotten throughout the HBO podcast
the creative team have talked about how
love is a big theme in the show and this
can be seen in every single aspect
ranges from Joel and Sarah Frank and
Bell chill and Ellie and Jill and Tess
it shows both the positives and negative
sides with us often Landing in the
ladder Camp when you love someone and
they're taken from you it can cause you
to be angry and vengeful which is very
much represented in Kathleen he's angry
over her brother's death and willing to
kill anyone who could have had a hand in
it and the trucks travel out and we see
graffiti on them saying we the people
these are the first three words in the
Constitution and the UCA signifies the
New Order they've brought in they very
much try to form a new state but whether
that's good or bad is another question
entirely we the people might also be
another not to taxi driver as the
campaign slogan in that was we are the
people now we also see the Run truck and
this pulls directly from the game in
which it plagued you at several points
there was an automatic gun on the top of
it that will constantly bear down on you
and you had to sneak your way through
the streets avoiding detection at all
costs as they drive through the streets
we can also make out the words [__]
bedra and in red spray paint on the back
the soldier just on the building and
homes looking for the fugitives Joel and
Ellie lie low in the high low bar and we
see newspapers covering the windows we
can see the Kansas City Star and a
headline about a U.S troop hunt entering
its third day as Joel sits down we see
him moving his hand almost like he's
stretching it out and it still Bears the
cut and his knuckles from smashing that
guy's face in like like it was the like
button smash the like button I said
and the conversation here plays out
slightly different to how it does in the
game which y'all basically trying to
come for Delhi he says that she
shouldn't have to shoot people because
she's just a kid and in the game he's
just very matter of fact about it
and just so we're clear about back there
it was either him or me
I'm sorry
yeah though he apologizes that she was
put in that position but she says it
wasn't the first time that she had to
kill someone he hands her the gun back
and shows her how to use it which
mirrors the moment in which he gives her
in the game about something there
a little more your size
it's for emergencies only
okay
show me your grip
Ellie was desperate to get a gun at the
start of episode 2 and though she's
finally happy to get one we know the
weight of the need for this outweighs
the fun Joel says to put it in her pack
otherwise she'll shoot your damn ass off
but she ignores this and puts it in her
pocket she might end up pulling this out
later on and it could be how they get
out of the situation with Henry and Sam
next week across town the search
continues with them discovering where
the pair had been hiding it's very
similar to what Anne Frank had to do
during the second world war and this
attic room above an office could be a
nod to that judging by the time of the
beans on the floor Sam and Henry were
possibly there for a couple of weeks and
we see drawings that Sam has made this
is him and his brother as superheroes
with orange masks over their eyes when
we see Henry at the end he has orange
face paint on like this which carries
Across From This Moment another Rebels
are through fedrat that doesn't mean
that they have control of the city in a
back room we see there's a crater in the
ground and this starts to move up and
down as we know the in fact did moved
underground and the fungus spread out
like telephone wires this ran for miles
and allowed the infected to build a hive
my network this is far more dangerous
than Henry and his little brother but
Kathleen's so focused on getting revenge
she doesn't want to deal with it they
sweep it under the rug but this has the
potential to actually bring the whole
city down and my guess is they're gonna
regret doing this now that night Joel
and Ellie sneak into a skyscraper and in
classic Last of Us fashion he gives her
a bunk up into a vent so that she can
lock the door this happened throughout
the game at several points with her
smaller size allowing her to open up
sealed areas now in order to be safe
they climb up as many steps as they can
and along the way we get this line
ripped right out of the game
hey you know the guy who said he was
hurt how do you know it was an ambush
how did you know no what about the
ambush
I've been on both sides
been on both sides
oh uh kill a lot of innocent people
like that as a yes
it was a long time ago we did what we
needed to survive
you and test
and the people we were with it really
shows the duplicity in Joel and how far
he fell after losing Sarah he was so set
on Surviving he didn't care what he had
to do to make it through the day and it
makes you wonder what went on in those
20 years it's something we've never
really been privy to in the game and I
honestly I don't know if we should ever
see it Joe is very much presented to us
as a hero but there's always this dark
side within him that sets up some of the
acts he commits you're always wondering
if there's more to the father figure
from Texas and add so much to his
character just having this Shadow side
to him now they make it 32 floors before
they duck into an office the fact that
Sam and Henry randomly end up in the
same one it signifies to me that it
wasn't random at all I actually think
that the pair followed them up there and
it's possible I'd been tracking them for
some time gel lay some glass on the
ground so that he can hear if anyone
sneaks up on them this is a trick I
learned from Tom Cruise when watching
mission impossible it doesn't end up
working and this clearly links to the
deafness that we get touched upon here
he's said he couldn't hear Brian
sneaking up on him and this is also how
Henry and Sam are able to sneak up on
them Ali asks if it's because he was
shot and in episode 3 he talked about
the scar beside his Temple this is where
a bullet cut him and it's possible that
this was caused by a soldier who fired
at him and Sarah he immediately changes
the conversation and ends up turning
back on the other side possibly because
the questions hang a little too close to
home now he sleeps with his right side
covered and this also explains why he
chose his position in the forest he
knows that his hearing is off and has to
account for it when he's awakened later
he's on the other side with his left ear
covered explaining why they were able to
sneak up on them a juxtaposing the
campfire scene from earlier this scene
is much darker with Joel asking about
her having to kill people eventually
though she does make a joke from the
book to lighten the mood and this goes
did you know diarrhea is hereditary
diarrhea is hereditary it runs in your
Gene you're once in your jeans
anyway they fall asleep laughing but the
mood is quickly changed with Joel waking
up to find Ellie being held at gunpoint
and Sam standing over him with one drawn
that takes us into a super smaller
section
so if you haven't played the game and
don't want things thrown then I
recommend that you turn off now now
first things first we have what we have
to talk about is of course Sam and Henry
as you can probably guess from the
Kathleen comments they they are wanted
people and they want to get out of the
city just as much as Joel and Ellie do
because of that there's gonna be a team
up and they'll know that have to work
together to make it past Kathleen all
the stuff involving her and them is made
up for the show and in the game they
were survivors from half bed that
entered Pittsburgh in order to get
supplies the military had a band In the
Zone and Henry and Sam suspected that
the place would end up with a power
Dynamic like Pittsburgh where kids were
killed off because they slowed down
others thus they headed out looking for
another quarantine Zone which is when
they pass through Pittsburgh at this
point they were attacked by hunters and
the group they were in ended up being
separated they'd agreed to Rendezvous at
a radio tower on the outskirts of the
city and this is the location they all
end up heading towards now in the game
as you are Never Getting Pittsburgh you
jumped into a room through a window and
at this point Henry ended up grabbing
you initially he thought you were a
hunter but he did start to question
things when Ellie attacked him Joel
almost killed him but his brother
sampled the gun on the pair setting up a
similar scene to what we end with here
and in the game it was Henry and Sam
that were the ones hiding out like Jill
and Ali here they took you to an
abandoned office building but they
turned it into a Hideout and you waited
out throughout the night before heading
out I'm guessing that will be what
happens in episode 5 with a group now
trying to escape this city and that's
where the other Easter eggs in the entry
we have the no pun intended book making
a big appearance this was actually given
to Ali by Riley and in the Left Behind
DLC she read it at several points I'm
guessing that she'll be the one to give
it to Ali in the show as we are said to
have a flashback episode with her now
when Ali was gazing over the Stars I was
also wondering if this was foreshadowing
the space scene that happens in part two
in that Jill takes Ellie to a museum for
her birthday and they climb into a
shuttle which is when he gives her some
headphones to listen to an Apollo left
off wearing an astronaut helmet she
imagines what it's like going up there
and I was wondering if this scene here
was setting up that down the line now
another thing they bring up is how Tommy
is in Cody he's actually in Jackson in
the game and this is about a five hour
drive from Cody all right so Kathleen
murdering a doctor I did think this
could potentially also be foreshadowing
Jill doing it down the line doctors are
very valuable in this new world because
so few people have the skills to be one
thus killing one is damning a lot of
people's lives that they could have
saved Kathleen does this and Jill does
this too in order to stop Ellie from
being operated on just something I
noticed and how the characters both did
it out of anger killing the doctor also
has dire repercussions for Joel as well
which at this point I'm pretty sure will
be happening in season two I know
there's there's still people out there
who think the show isn't Gonna Do the
Mario Golf Scene but hey to break your
teammate uh they've been very game
accurate here so I think they probably
are now the last spoilery Easter egg
happens with the recess in the floor now
if you listen closely you can actually
hear the sound of a blowder [__]
[Music]
this teases at them popping up in the
future and potentially we might get to
see one next week these highly infected
monsters through acidic spores at you
and they were actually teased in episode
two so there aren't super infected that
explode fungus spores on you [__] I hope
not obviously Kathleen and Co they
shouldn't have left this unchecked and
that tiny little door it's not gonna
hold the blower back so fingers crossed
that we get it next week and as for this
episode I think this was another great
one that perfectly managed to adapt the
game whilst changing some things to make
it more like TV unfortunately I don't
think we're ever getting to the hotel
now as we're way past that point but the
human drama has been enough to keep me
hooked I think this is probably I'm
gonna be controversial I think this is
probably my least favorite of the four
so far but it's it's difficult to really
judge you for that because you know the
other one set such a high bar this also
feels like it's a two-parter so you
can't really judge it on that because
they haven't concluded this store yet
now I can't wait to see how it plays out
either way and obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you drop them below we are in
competition right now giving away three
copies of wakanda Forever on the 15th of
February and all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on also drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
repeat the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out one of our last
of us breakdowns on screen right now go
head over there I'm bloody telling you
head over there now if not then thanks
for singing to the video I'll be poor
let's see you next time take care